dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here we
recently talked about an amazing paper
that uses mixture theory to simulate the
interaction of liquids and fabrics and
this new work is about simulating fluid
flows where we have some debris or other
foreign particles in our liquids this is
really challenging for example one of
the key challenges is incorporating
two-way coupling into this process this
means that the sand is allowed to have
an effect on the fluid but at the same
time as the fluid sloshes around it also
moves the sand particles within now
before you start wondering whether this
is real footage or not the fact that
this is a simulation should become clear
now because what you see here in the
background is where the movement of the
two domains are shown in isolation just
look at how much interaction there is
between the two unbelievable
beautiful simulation ice cream for your
eyes this new method also contains a
novel density correction step and if you
watch closely here you'll notice why got
it let's watch it again if we try to run
this elasto-plastic simulation for these
two previous methods they introduce here
again in density or in other words we
end up with more stuff than we started
with
these two rows show the number of
particles in the simulation in the worst
case scenario and as you see some of
these incorporate millions of particles
for the fluid and many hundreds of
thousands for the sediment since this
work uses the material point method
which is a hybrid simulation technique
that uses both particles and grids the
Delta X row denotes the resolution of
the simulation grid now since these
grids are often used for 3d simulations
we need to raise the 256 and the 512 to
the third power and with that we get a
simulation grid with up to hundreds of
millions of points and we haven't even
talked about the particle representation
yet in the face of all of these
challenges the simulator is able to
compute one frame in a matter of minutes
and not hours or days which is an
incredible feat with this I think it is
easy to see that computer graphics
research is improving at a staggering
pace what a time to be alive if you
enjoyed this episode please consider
supporting us through patreon our
address is patreon.com slash two minute
papers or just click the link in the
video description with this we can make
better videos for you you can also get
your name immortalized in the video
description as a key supporter or watch
these videos earlier than others thanks
for watching and for your generous
support and I'll see you next time